if you guys haven't heard the
governments of the world and their
Infinite Wisdom are planning to ban the
sale of new internal combustion engines
by in and around 2035 I think it is is
that is that the yeah 2030 or 2035 yeah
yeah get the map that shows the
countries that are trying to ban
internal combustion engines by 2035 and
you'll see it's such a small portion of
the globe
but but what you're forgetting dragas is
that these mind viruses start somewhere
and then they in fact I mean I mean look
look look at it 20 years ago all right
here here it is right here this is oh
this is where it starts these bratty
purple-haired nerds check this out
line it's quite easy it's not actually
true it's easy to find it's a million
but that's not it costs around 20 000
pounds to insulate a British home so
that's 8 000 British homes for 115
million which is what it says online
which is aren't true but do you really
think that you're worth more than 8 000
cold freezing exactly have you seen the
studies on insulation
that insulation you care about the
people living in fuel poverty um very
much so when I was Secretary of State
for energy I was responsible for
developing the plan that has brought
Energy prices down for families that was
policy that I was intimately involved in
designing so of course I care about that
so you don't understand
what happens three years after people
have insulated their homes they use the
same amount of energy as they did before
there's been a study on this which I'm
sure you've seen reports on in the first
year they saved money in the second year
they save a small amount of money in the
third year they have actually made
themselves warmer because
um the economics of it is they have a
certain amount they can spend on what
happens when the government fails to
insulate British homes 7.5 million
British people live in fuel those are
big programs are starving themselves
she's not listening well she I don't
know let's just go with they them are
not listening to a word
that children and people are freezing to
death in their homes because they are
forced to choose between Heating and
eating because people are dying are you
hearing me because it's simply not true
aren't they aren't they always just
experts at spending other people's money
oh I looked up your net worth online so
if we take your net worth and then
distribute it amongst twenty thousand uh
pound insulation rates on the poor and
the impoverished in the UK then their
houses will be warm this winter right
like let's just steal your money
distribute it amongst these people and
then what he's saying is basically yeah
fine so they'll be warmer for the first
year or so but then after that in three
years time they'll be in the same spot
which is factually true people that are
irresponsible that don't take ownership
for their lives you give somebody a
million dollars it just wins the lottery
they're poor within two years usually
right they've gone and blown it all
anyway so this is where this mind virus
starts right like this notion that you
know internal combustion engines are bad
or they're wrong now they've studied
this
I want to say this you know because
they've studied this there's lots of
videos out there breaking it down from a
factual scientific perspective that
battery-powered vehicles are not net
positive for the environment until they
hit like 80 000 miles before that's
terrible they actually do worse damage
to the environment prior to that and in
reality if you've got yourself set up
correctly with
which you will let's say by 2035 I bet
you they'll they'll find ways to improve
the efficiency of the internal
combustion engine even further so that
it produces less
um sorry 50. I gotta need it because
you're because you've got birds singing
in the background I'll let you chime in
a second
um but like they actually have uh tell
the birds to shut up they actually have
a fuel production facility in Chile
Porsche just bought this business
there's a fuel production facility in
Chile that extracts carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere mixes it with some other
chemicals and gives you petroleum
gasoline refined gas that you can burn
in your car like any other gas you pull
it up pull out a pump right now the cost
of extraction is about 40 40 bucks a
gallon but they can definitely get that
cost down so it's completely carbon
neutral the notion that battery powered
cars where you have these children in
Cobalt mines in the Congo poisoning
themselves getting this chemical under
their skin under their nails you know in
their eyes and all this like these kids
are dying to make couple cents a day so
that people can feel virtuous about
charging their Teslas right well what
they don't realize is that every time
they come up with a legislation banks
are sorry companies always find a way
around it you're familiar with the cafe
standards here in the United States yeah
and it's carbon something it's called
Fleet equivalent so you have a fleet
equivalent you're in like Chevy's entire
fleet has to come in at X miles per
gallon so you know what Chevy do because
they make most of their money on trucks
and so do Ford have you ever seen those
things that are like a loaf of bread on
Wheels the Chevy Avail yeah it's like
you could kick it you could kick it over
if you lost your temper badly enough do
you know why you know why Chevy makes
that
they make that because when you put it's
mile it's called fleece equivalent when
you average it out so if you put
something in to your you know your big
gas goes on V8s and all that and you got
to measure it across the 23 cars that
you make when you put the Aveo in and it
gets 34 miles to the gallon it takes the
average down below so and this is
these you know as I said to Rich during
the week we didn't get the internet by
Banning you know phone lines we didn't
get the um airplane by Banning ocean
liners so these morons think that you
know by Banning cars and generally these
are people that all work in office
blocks in high density cities policy
makers and they generally aren't out in
the real world and they think that
everybody has husband wife two two and a
half kids and they can all drive a Ford
or sedan and commute 15 minutes to work
and what they don't realize is that you
know the people that provide their food
and their furniture and build their
houses need things a little bigger and a
more powerful and a little more
convenient and cheaper
you know what these people are best
described as people that never play to
win they play only not to lose
yeah well they don't even know what
they're playing if you know for being
honest it's just about feels it's like
well I feel like if I just drive an
electric car I'll save the environment
and [__] capitalism and let's dismantle
the patriarchy and block like they don't
have any logical reasoning that looks at
scientific I feel like gas cars are bad
it's like yeah just like the lady
the lady that was argument Mark Reese in
the video he showed I mean we all know
what her parents house looks like it
probably looks very big and she comes
from an athlone background but she's
like you don't care about poor people in
Britain it's always like okay there's a
difference between caring and doing you
can care about everybody but are you
going to do anything you know dye your
hair blue and dress like
you know a pixie and yell at somebody
I always say something like that too
like how many poor people live with you
how many people have you brought in off
the street when you walk by a homeless
person do you stop and help them out no
you do like all of us do you're like oh
stay away from that guy he's a weirdo
and you just go about your life yeah I
think it actually relates to the video
that rich had played earlier in that it
it corresponds with personal
responsibility though so like 20 30
years ago like you had your personal
responsibility you'd say there's things
that are certain things that I can do
certain things that I can't do okay so
now you have these politicians that say
oh the the the environment is warming
which it is it isn't that's not the
point they say you know give me your
vote and I can stop the environment from
warming I can stop this virus I can stop
your children from doing XYZ though
right when they really don't even have
the power to do that but
again it's offloading the responsibility
from yourself to the government right do
you know what I mean
government a millionaire a billionaire
you know whatever it happens to be it's
it's it's
it just doesn't add up man like every
time you know you see these purple
haired weirdos talking about their
virtuous ways of saving the planet it's
like most of the stuff they talk about
doesn't you don't need to get involved
in but there's nothing to save you know
climate has been changing for millions
of years climate change is not new
of years and it will continue to change
we're not having that much of an impact
on it yeah
I have a relative that constantly posts
stuff about saving the bees save the
bees save the bees they live in a they
live in a large city save the bees and
most of their efforts to save the bees
generally involves legislation and given
more power to the government I generally
ignore it but a few weeks ago I counted
on my property I have 57 lavender plants
and lavender plants are they're like
crack cocaine beans so I come to them
and I said um I've planted 57 lavender
plants on my property what are you doing
posting on Facebook yeah yeah what the
BC or Facebook post because they're out
they're out there doing lines of
lavender and my plants every morning
why are like these types of chicks so
overweight because that requires energy
like really if you want to save the
planet you'd walk everything but they're
all vegan yeah right they're all vegan
dude saving the planet which is insane
yeah like John energy or nutrition dense
food okay dude you just hit on something
great you could say obesity is bad for
the environment because you calculate
how many how many kilocalories
kilojoules whatever they have to consume
every day so a fifth person you know is
is leaner and is more efficient so you
take in 2 000 calories a day jiren
you're gonna be a lot more efficient so
they're these overweight obese people
are generally like V8 you know 12 mile
per gallon engines so they need to
energy equation yeah
let's ban them let's start Banning them
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go full on
Hardcore with you on this one because I
always see this stuff you know this
argument from uh they call them bigger
people you know on planes because they
don't fit in the seats and you know
they're always lobbying to have bigger
seats and you know reasonable seat space
and they're always the same they're
always like three or four pound
heffalumpolus and um you know I get the
argument like coach seats in the back
suck uh I mean if I have a long flight I
always sit in front like I'm not I'm not
sitting in those little [__] [__]
seats but
they like to charge like Airlines want
to charge you extra money for your extra
baggage but they never charge fat people
extra money why aren't they putting
people on a scale when they go and check
in and get their tickets and if you
weigh more than the average person your
height and weight for your height and
age you know let's say charging them
more money for the extra fuel they have
to put on the plane to haul their fat
ass around right I got to pay extra
money for a 50 pound bag why aren't they
paying extra extra money for the extra
50 pounds that they're carrying around
some of them are carrying around 100 200
extra pounds right you see what I'm
saying here you don't they could make
even more money by charging people to
sit and watch the fat people being
weighed on the scale like cattle that
will charge it by pound
I would sit there with my popcorn and
just watch like wow look at this one
what do you think this one weighs
we're gonna get banned here I'm gonna
have to set up like a rumble Stream So
that we only streams
we're gonna run into problems at some
points
with Disneyland in California
on Disney World they actually did have a
thing saying if if you're too overweight
you can't you can't ride this ride
because you're gonna break the ride and
then people who are mad people were
complaining about the things they're
like oh what do we do these these fat
people you know these fat cells keep
breaking our ride right so what are we
gonna do we keep wiping on the
environment hey it's because of global
warming guys like there's nothing we can
do about it yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out